remember that you can get 70 off a david
pakman show membership
using the coupon code fresh start why
because we're taking a fresh start here
it's a new beginning
uh use that coupon code fresh start all
one word all lowercase
to discount the membership of your
choice at joinpacman.com
i have something completely shocking to
report to you
president-elect joe biden has announced
his coronavirus
task force there's not a single member
of his family on it
none of joe biden's family is on the
task force
not a single pillow salesman is on the
task force
there's no faith healers on the task
force it's just doctors
the task force includes seven doctors
david kessler a pediatrician
a former surgeon general um dr marcela
nunez smith who's a professor of
epidemiology at yale
dr rick bright an immunologist and
vaccine researcher who refused to do
trump's propaganda bidding
dr zeke emanuel who's a bioethicist dr
atul gawande
surgeon and public health expert dr
michael osterholm another
epidemiologist actually having have an
atul gawande story atul gawande wrote
this great book the checklist manifesto
and when i had my appendectomy um 2 am
in the morning this was like a year ago
surgeon comes in dr matthew nays says
hey here's who i am here's the office i
work in and his specialty was
i think it was like endocrinology
surgery it just sounded a lot like what
i know
dr atul gawande's specialty is i'm all
zoned out in the middle you know i'm on
drugs appendectomy all this stuff
and i say do you know atul gawande
and he says i do it's my office mate
or whatever and at that point i at least
hoped i was in good hands i was very
drugged up it was easy to convince me
that i was and it worked out great but
anyway
dr atul gawande really good guy great
inclusion
but a group of just doctors with
relevant specializations and a picture
of their first meeting was released joe
biden
yes joe biden already has held his first
coronavirus task force meeting
he's still months out from being
president joe biden just sat there
taking notes you see if you're looking
at the picture of the meeting
there was no tv on in the back of the
room so if joe biden got bored he could
watch fox news or something
so obviously i'm being sort of jokey but
this is very serious this is a real
change in the trajectory of the u.s
dealing with coronavirus in that the
president will deal with it and will
deal with it with relevant doctors
no media figures no radiologists saying
let's go for herd immunity
no tv anchors no nonsense and the one
little flavor i like
is that the inclusion of rick bright in
this group
of doctors is very likely to heavily
trigger donald trump you might remember
dr rick bright
was a trump whistleblower who came out
and said they're pushing me
to start saying things about
hydroxychloroquine that are not based in
fact and of course
rick bright was correct nobody talks
about hydroxychloroquine anymore he was
one of the
few people doing good work at the time
and
uh he blew the whistle and his inclusion
here
is very likely to trigger donald trump
now there was a question
why no fouchy where is dr fauci why is
dr
fauci not part of this my assumption is
that joe biden understands
dr fauci is running nih
he is a you know loosely speaking an
administration employee
and it would not really be appropriate
to include him in this group
right now i'm sure that if
donald trump fires dr fauci or
uh when dr uh when when joe biden is
inaugurated
dr fauci is going to be a part of this
there is no question whatsoever
i don't think fauci is sitting there you
know rigging is
wringing his hands wondering if he will
be useful to the incoming administration
i'm sure he knows that he will be
and i think joe biden is probably
probably doing the appropriate thing
by not yet including him but we're
already off to you know
this is going to be a long fight and
we're going to need to wear masks for
for some time and things are not going
to be normal for some time but
this is a start that certainly inspires
some confidence one of our sponsors
today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100
of your money if you don't love it no
questions asked
go to magicspoon.com pacman to build
your own
custom variety box today make sure to
use promo code pacman to get free
shipping
the link is right underneath this video